elle est comme chaque soir durant ces
grandes vacances notre page était elle
vous emmène encore durant trois jours
découvrir notre belle sologne et c'est
avec flavien texier qui est aujourd'hui
en direct des étangs de saint viâtre
dans le loir-et-cher bonsoir flavien
bonsoir et bk je vous attendais avec
impatience pour vous faire effectivement
partager cette grande balade en sologne
que nous avons organisées tout au long
du week-end rebecca vous avez dit c'est
l'été je ne vous cache pas que ce soir
il fait un petit peu froid ici mais
c'est pas grave on va passer un
excellent moment vous l'avez dit on va
parler des étangs et on va en parler
tout de suite avec laeticia marion qui
nous accompagne depuis la mi-journée
bonsoir laetitia vous êtes vous êtes
guide touristique ici vous connaissez
parfaitement ces endroits
combien y at il des temps en sologne en
sologne vous avez à peu près trois mille
étangs de plus de deux hectares et ils
ont été créés au xième siècle pour la
pisciculture essentiellement et pour
faire des réserves d'eau parce qu on les
utilisait pour faire la lessive pour les
femmes pour faire boire les troupeaux et
puis aussi beaucoup la pisciculture
essentiellement la pisciculture
alors je le disais vous travaillez à la
maison des étangs c'est le point de
départ un petit peu c'est l'endroit où
on se retrouve
oui à la maison des étangs en fait on
vous fait découvrir l'histoire des
étangs leur fonctionnement
quand est-ce qu'ils ont été créés pour
quoi et puis tout ce qui gravitaient
autour les petits métiers comme la
fabrication des barques la fabrication
des bombes
et puis on peut donner des indications
sur les balades à faire pour aller voir
les étangs et quelles sont les activités
proposées aujourd'hui autour de ces
étangs aujourd'hui les étangs sont
essentiellement exploiter pour la
pisciculture la chasse au gibier d'eau
et puis la pêche à la ligne
la pêche à la ligne ça tombe bien on va
voir un reportage que nous avons réalisé
cet après midi les images sont signés
etienne braye leçon c'est philippe roy
le montage thomas guillet regar des donc
je hais les rations de pêche tout le
monde est votre carte de pêche s'il vous
plaît aucun programme visite de routine
pour ce gars de pêche fédérale
un petit contrôle pour s'assurer que
tout va bien tout est en règle
car fais pas de souci et puis broad
futur agréable de discuter avec les
pêcheurs également le contact est
généralement très bon et ça permet aussi
de recueillir beaucoup d'informations
donc là on a parlé des gros brochet par
exemple moi j'ai su qu'il y avait un
mehdi cela monsieur me confier à m donc
c'est déjà des poissons c'est important
bienvenue à l'étang du mois un plan
d'eau de 9 hectares gérés par la
fédération du loir et cher
un site très apprécié des pêcheurs
c'est vraiment un très beau plan d'eau
très accessible moi je viens de temps en
temps avec mes enfants c'est vraiment
très pratique et des jolis poissons quoi
il vraiment possible de pouvoir faire
quelques gros mon jeu et à l'étang du
moins se côtoient de nombreuses variétés
sept à huit au total
un plan d'eau qui a reçu un label
national
un label qui impose une règle très
strictes il est classé en no kill
donc c'est à dire qu'on ne tue pas on
remet à l'eau toutes les prises donc là
en fait on va remettre à l'eau tous les
carnassiers donc le brochet
principalement puisque ce site là et
très peuplée de projets un étang idéal
pour pratiquer cette activité que l'on
soit amateur ou pêcheurs confirmés
retour ici à saint viâtre en direct
laetitia marion on l'a vu il y à la
discipline et il ya aussi des étangs ont
fait de la production
oui on fait beaucoup de enfin on fait
pas mal de pisciculture alors faut
savoir que pour récupérer les poissons
on fait pareil qu'au moyen âge on vide
envie de les étangs ça se fait à peu
près tous les ans et puis ça se passe
d'octobre jusqu'à janvier février
c est en jeu le disais tout à l'heure
vous fait visiter vous les fait visiter
pardon vous les connaissez bien
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de qu'est-ce qui vous
fascine ici c'est vrai que ce paysage
déjà est quand même assez magnifique et
puis les temps ça amène beaucoup de vie
que ce soit au niveau des oiseaux au
niveau des petites bêtes comme les
salamandres enfin voilà ça fait ou les
tritons et ça apporte ça amène de la vie
voilà tout simplement et c'est ça qui
est fascinant parce que chaque jour
c'est sait jamais le même paysage
à chaque fois ça change on voit pas les
mêmes espèces d'oiseaux et c'est ça qui
est vraiment formidable
rien qu'à saint viâtre je crois il y en
a une centaine c'est ça il y en a à peu
près cent trente-cinq où il ya saint
viâtre assembler 235 c'est une très
grande commune donc voila merci en tout
cas merci infiniment de nous avoir servi
en quelque sorte de guide ce soir merci
à vous les titien marion demain rebecca
changement de programme radical on reste
bien sûr en soleil mais on sera à
chaumont-sur-tharonne pour la 5e
biennale
demain on fait de l'art et bk merci
beaucoup flavie en a dit être à demain